daniel is in nashville hi daniel how are
you
hi dave hi anthony thanks for taking my
call yeah what's up
um so my wife got my wife and i got
married about a year and a half ago
we graduated about two years ago and we
set a goal for about five years we want
to
move outside of the united states um to
just share the the love of christ with a
place that doesn't know it yet
and so right now we're living in
nashville we're both teachers here and
we're going to move
closer to home to new mexico and so our
plan was to buy a house for about five
years and then to sell it and then leave
but just with the way the market has
kind of exploded over the last
six months 12 months 18 months we
are just not quite sure what to do i've
run some numbers in an excel spreadsheet
so i have my own idea but i was i was
curious about what you would do if
you're in my shoes
what are y'all going to do in nashville
i mean they're leaving nashville
mexico to new mexico are y'all going to
be missionary work or are you going to
still teach
and we plan on continuing to teach
for five years still okay so we're
building up a war chest to do the
mission field
after five years is that right yeah just
growing in maturity okay in our marriage
and
professionalism all that stuff good for
you okay good
well obviously if the housing market
continues like it is for five years
which it won't
um you would be more than okay buying a
house right
definitely because you'd make a brazil
you'd make a bazillion dollars but
i'm not assuming that's going to happen
and i'm guessing you aren't either
that's right so what is your fear of
buying a house and holding it five years
um i'm just not sure what the timelines
are for like when it's better to rent
versus when it's better
to buy some something say two years
something say
you know you should have at least seven
years on the higher end but
i think after running the numbers i
think five years is safe but what i
don't want to happen is like
the the same sort of bubble that
happened like 12 years ago 10 years ago
or so
um and then you know we because people
are overpaying about
you know 15 or 20 000 asking price um
and so yeah i don't want to overpay by
you know 20 000 and then
the uh the house is not worth
as much and we end up paying more um
trying to just like resell the house
than we would have if we had rented for
five years
okay none of us know what the market is
going to do exactly
and um but i i do not do
anything financially predicated on
the crash and the end of the world
okay if i'm going to do that then we
just need to
buy bullets and water
and a tent right so i don't i don't but
could real estate uh offset if you go
back and actually look at the numbers
and
and the bubble of 2008 was a real estate
bubble that burst
right it was the first one some of the
variables going here
other than the great depression it's the
only time we've had a we've had some
economic downturns but we've never had a
real estate downturn like 2008 was but
here's the interesting thing
in almost every market within five years
it had fully recovered
okay i mean look at the history of it
you can look at that's a database thing
that's not a feeling
and so you know i remember saying well
you know the
people saying well you know scottsdale
arizona phoenix arizona oh my god
you know it was artificially high it
dove vegas took a big drop
it was the fastest growing city in
america and it dropped
way down most areas dropped down it was
the first time we'd seen
homes single-family homes actually go
down in value in some of these markets
they were all back in three years
okay they were and that was a dramatic
one
now so now the question then is how much
money are you gonna make or are you in a
stagnant market so here's two
here's a couple of numbers if you want
to nerd out further on it just for the
fun of it
get with the real estate agent out there
and
number one you got to be debt free right
anthony yep you got to have the
emergency fund
got every down payment before we even
talk about this but assuming you've done
that
you put it on a 15-year fixed rate where
the payment's no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay these are the
guidelines we use around here
so you don't buy too much house and you
don't buy a house when you're broke but
once you're doing all that then you can
look at two statistics
with your real estate agent out there
and uh
i would say pre-2020 i wouldn't use 2020
numbers or 2021 numbers because they're
they are unusually high in terms of how
fast properties have gone up in value
there's very few times in history you
can look back and see this much
escalation in value
or cost on property uh this fast
so i would say you know like 18 17 18 19
in this market pull up on the mls for me
ask the real estate agent
what the average appreciation rate was
in the neighborhood that you're
considering
okay okay and then that will tell you if
you're going to make enough during your
holding period to offset your costs
okay so you would just take that rate
and then that would be the rate i would
use
because that's probably more average
than what we're experiencing right now
that's you know what we're experiencing
right now i don't think is going to
continue for five years that's
unrealistic
i could be wrong but i don't i don't
think so the second thing you can ask
them for and this might be the most
important number in this whole
conversation is ask them for average dom
prior to 2020 average days on the market
how hot a market is this and if the
average dom
on a house the price range you're
looking at is 270 days that's nine
months don't buy
you're gonna get stuck but if the
average dom is nine days
prior to 2020 then that market was hot
before the pandemic
i see and you know you got markets that
were that way already they were already
running
20-day 30-day 40-day doms
and if you've got average days on the
market then that market's going to move
you'll be able to get out of the house
i'm not as concerned about how much
you're going to make on it i'm fairly
comfortable you're going to make some
money
but i am concerned you can't sell it
when you get ready to leave and you end
up with a rental property in the states
and you're on the mission field
oh shoot me get it over with i hate that
idea
sounds good does that make sense to you
yeah yeah hey man good question and
thank you for your
willingness to serve the lord in that
way very very cool